hello and welcome to this video
plane hmm nine can yeah we'll see what
happens
one thing that I need to mention is that
there won't be any videos in them in
this week only now here on Monday
recording this on the day of release
currently I don't do any pre-production
you want to call it like that and this
week I'm not going to be at home I'm
leaving tomorrow morning to be one of
the coaches form the chess team of my
state here in Germany for the junior
state championships and yeah I'm not
able to do anything besides besides
preparing the kids and maybe I can do a
little bit of writing but I won't have
probably any good and internet access so
there's no way I managed to record
anything okay so we have a we have a me
think about it this one it's a silly in
here which should be five check and this
set up with C 3 and so on that has some
rule no pass kind of flavor whites
position at least and black decided to
go for this flexible set up okay I'm not
really sure what black is trying to do
here he's some regrouping but not sure
what his intention is because I mean
yeah it's not so easy to play without
any
porn in the center and not sure what
those nights you know what they what
Center he is trying to try to create the
seagoing form E 5 hoping for D 5 and
that's actually strange I want to play B
3 anyway at least that is a way to play
yeah B should be true hmm I don't know
if I want to do that
because if he castles the idea to play
for our sacrifice well and Bishop b2
also was good the idea to play for our
sacrifice on h6 is pretty obvious well
that's weird
now I'm winning before for nothing on
some other material
it's how he played it um but I have
really recognized that sometimes those
positions and then our fairly non
Sicilian okay if I take if I take there
is d5
okay there is d5
but remarkable and then after a queen
movie will take on e4 and win material
odd in any way I mean I'm just better so
I don't really need to grab this pawn to
be better I can just play normal moves
but it's funny that this opportunity
exists anyway Brooke c1 is is just good
I think it doesn't have anything great
in this position and um and I already
see a good move here from back you can
go d5 but and now I can take and play d5
just one day and let's let's do it it
cannot be bad to get to Bishop to c8 do
I need rooks e1 or not I can also play
d5 yeah I still like Roxy one
he will probably castle even though it's
scarier it is scary to castle okay oh
okay no t5 I mean what must be right so
if I take it and I can check e6y can
take six immediately in the night deform
my stuff to say what's best Jim I don't
see an immediate technical win and wait
I can take wait I can take and then take
a six huh
Bishop a six and this position wins a
pause just time in
I wonder if that is strongest because
blacks position is so terrible and might
might be something else but in okay
it's upon night takes is not working due
to the pin and Queen takes Bishop c5
wins the pawn and probably more than a
pawn
okay just retreat so I'm going to go
back as well I have Knight d4 Knight f1
I mean it's just huge pressure so let's
do this
I don't you how to play e5 you know open
everything up as much as possible that
must must be at least a viable option
[Music]
should takes takes only 7 or do I have
anything better looks like I should have
anything better this one okay I mean
it's just one continuation of many looks
great
okay don't have all that much time
threatening multiform we want to treat
Queen sir this King position is really
bad
so no Queen trade Queen b6 was an idea
and I'm winning the Queen at least okay
yeah that didn't work out too well in
this opening it was I think quite okay
observe up to hear it I mean what white
must be a little bit better man is this
is a blue tender and but it's not
nothing in particular
no and now 96 okay not quite sure where
this is going but you may be free of the
square but okay rook e1 age six not
strictly necessary and makes short
castling more difficult you know it got
very strange I really have no clue where
those pieces are supposed to go at the
end yeah know what now Knight c4 I just
lose this time and this place is the
piece I mean that's just a bad piece on
a 5k Bishop b3 and now Luke c3 at the
next odd one
I play Queen d2 quite quickly and yeah I
have this suspicion that d5 was
interesting I mean no there is probably
some tactical idea but just like it's
interesting to play like that because
the knight now has no square absolutely
no square and that could be technically
of dangerous for black and is it is
strong that is very strong something
like this I'm threatening Bishop D form
I mean this is this this is just winning
the d5 is very strong I played this
really a bit too quickly
um yeah before 92 blocks the ADA it's
funny that I cannot take I mean then d5
and I'm losing yeah really really
strange in some way okay I played a
normal move don't ask me why I didn't
take the other look that would have been
more logical actually I don't know
okay Queen to b6 take da Kruk c1 and now
king d8 you have a lot of happy move of
course but what what is he supposed to
play and like here Bishop h6 already
wins I would have played 93 because he
has no way to prevent it and this is
probably just devastating a5 and this
one or Knight f4 is even stronger okay
it looks terrible terrible it's not it's
a nice line rook c8 and that is so one
how exactly is it and I can take because
95 is such a threat yeah this is just
one check okay I cleaned eh well you
have to make and make a move it's just
just not going to work out
yeah Bishop a6 is probably not the best
I mean okay it's a pawn Knight f4 Knight
d4 is stronger but it's not a bad bad
things just get pocket to the pawn and
then see what happens I think here there
are very there multiple ways of doing
near the e5 I'm fairly certain that here
I have something stronger than ninety
six Queen to f4
96 is not bad it just keeps keeps a huge
advantage I Bishop b5 would have been
good yeah but okay this is not bad not
bad either yeah it's just it's just too
easy okay guys thanks for watching